on est bien peu de chose et mon amie la
rose me l'a dit ce matin à nos morts je
suis me disais de rentiers
je me suis épanoui
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre émission
le petit émir lors du premier épisode
vous avez pu découvrir le principe de
cette émission nous allons suivre durant
toute la saison les étapes de la
création d'une pièce de théâtre par une
troupe de comédiens porteurs de handicap
la dernière fois nous avons suivi marica
lors de la première séance de casting au
collège
adrien cerneaux c'était l'occasion pour
adeline zidane paulo et tous leurs amis
de montrer leur talent de mime avec ce
second épisode nous vous emmenons à la
maison d'accueil spécialisée de sainte
suzanne à la découverte de flavie ingrid
mathias et les autres participants de
l'atelier
certains d'entre eux feront ils partie
de la troupe nous le saurons en suivant
marica dans la suite de son casting
mathias est ce que tu veux bien faire
les échauffements ok on y va c'est
partit ensuite l'atelier commence par un
échauffement corporel et vocal qui
permet de mettre à l'aise les comédiens
une fois les bras aux seins de toi ok ok
l'échauffement bocal maintenant qu'on a
fait le corps maintenant à bien la voix
parce que le théâtre c'est le corps et
la mort
la voir
à
ok
après l'échauffement corporelle et
vocale place aux exercices de groupe sur
le thème du oui et du non on a fini donc
l'échauffement maintenant on va passer à
des exercices
ok alors on fait le oui non non non
marica propose maintenant un match
d'improvisation sur le thème de la
dispute à la télévision qui saura se
montrer convaincant vous avez envie de
faire la bise
la dispute à la télé
en quelques minutes les comédiens
préparer ensemble leurs improvisations
et les présente à leurs camarades alors
qu'en pense le coach marica nous livre
ses premières impressions
donc c'est un peu à chaque fois comme un
ping pour vous faut laisser l'autre
parler et ensuite on parle sinon on
s'entend plus d'accord donc attention à
ça ça à nice
vas-y place fois bonjour bonjour mon
regard des bas est ce que je pourrai
seul
ok bravo ats c'est très bien il avait
aussi ok on y va nous partons à la
rencontre de cécile qui va nous en
apprendre davantage sur l'organisation
du projet alors je m'appelle cécile
ropéro je suis chargé de mission pour la
fée ap
c'est la fédération des établissements
hospitaliers et d'aidé à la personne
on avait en tête depuis bientôt un an de
faire un spectacle interassociatif on
avait on en avait parlé on n'avait
jamais eu l'occasion de le réaliser et
là on s'est lancé on a eu la proposition
de monter le spectacle enfin la pièce de
théâtre du petit émir et on a deux
associations qui souhaitent participer
qui sont l'asfa y lire sam et donc on
démarre c'est tout nouveau
c'est très intéressant mais du coup tu
as trouvé celui que tu voulais au niveau
des petits tenir des jeux mathias je
passe tu as vu l'un celui qui va donc
lui il a des capacités de mémoire et
tout bon après faut que je le vois et en
individuel voir si vraiment il est
capable 2 mais oui je pense qu'il a les
capacités
pas pour le rôle du petit émir pour le
narrateur celui qui va un peu faire la
course du paris-dakar ouais je pense que
ça fait c'était donc le second épisode
en compagnie des pensionnaires de la
maison d'accueil spécialisée de sainte
suzanne marie cas at-elle repéré un
talent qui fera partie de la troupe
vous le saurez en suivant les émissions
à venir dans le prochain épisode
nous poursuivrons le casting au centre
de la ressource à saint denis
à très bientôt